si puedes de planning lukashenko ya
están reunidos con algunos asuntos muy
importantes sobre la mesa aunque sabemos
que están reunidos a solas que no va a
haber periodistas después de que no se
plantea firmar hoy por lo menos ningún
tipo de documento en todo caso tanto
putin como lukashenko saben que las
opciones son ya conocidas desde hace
años lo que ocurre es que ahora lo que
hacen con se encuentra en una situación
de más debilidad y es una buena
oportunidad para moscú para forzar un
acuerdo lo primero bases rusas en
bielorrusia una posibilidad que preocupa
a algunos vecinos como por ejemplo
ucrania o lituania que temen por la
seguridad de sus fronteras y otro
segundo aspecto que el propio lukashenko
ha ido retrasando para no perder poder
durante estos últimos años es una mayor
integración no sólo económica sino tal
vez incluso política de bielorrusia y
rusia de manera que incluso bielorrusia
podría pasar a ser parte
de la gran federación rusa xavier en
otros temas destacados allí en rusia
este país está en plena jornada
electoral en 41 regiones que conforman
la federación están eligiendo
gobernadores asambleas regionales
municipales incluso cuatro diputados del
parlamento nacional como está avanzando
la jornada
bueno pues sigue el recuento y todavía
en muchos sitios no hay datos oficiales
pero lo que sabemos ahora es que en
efecto vladimir putin mantiene también
su poder regional y local pero con
algunos importantes y sorprendentes
avances de las fuerzas de la oposición
extraparlamentaria que comanda alexei
naval y es muy curioso porque
precisamente en la ciudad donde fue
envenenado hace casi un mes al xxi naval
y han conseguido una importante victoria
estamos hablando de toms una importante
ciudad universitaria del este del país
también en novosibirsk donde
precisamente uno de los principales
aliados de alexéi navalni ha conseguido
derrotar en la circunscripción electoral
municipal al hombre de rusia unida en
esa en esa ciudad así que dentro de él
el equipo de álex y naval y hoy ante el
optimismo por unas victorias modestas
pero que al mismo tiempo eran
inimaginables hace unos pocos años hay
que decir xavier que novosibirsk es la
tercera ciudad más grande de la
federación de rusia muchas gracias por
este informe desde moscú